[Musique]
macron a besoin d'un traitement pour sa
santé mentale et nageurs et athéna et
que pourrait-on dire d'autre à propos
d'un chef d'état qui ne comprend pas la
liberté de croyance et qui traitent des
millions de membres de communautés
religieuses différentes vivant dans son
pays de cette manière
la turquie ne peut pas se comporter de
cette manière la vérité aujourd'hui
c'est que on ne peut pas laisser cela
propager et prospérer parce que sinon
qu'est ce qu'on risque on risque que ça
s'enflamme encore davantage dans nos
territoires de la république en france
et ailleurs
ces rayons vides c'est le résultat de
l'appel au boycott des produits français
lancé en cette fin de semaine au
moyen-orient au koweït ces images de
célèbre fromage à tartiner retirés des
étals font le tour des réseaux sociaux
tout comme ces photos de manifestants
prenant à partie emmanuel macron et la
france réponse immédiate de l'elysée
l'ambassadeur de france en turquie a été
rappelé à paris
le rappel est un acte est un geste
significatif
on peut pas non plus dire que c'est un
geste fort car toute une série de
questions se posent
qu'est ce que l'on fait que la turquie
je vous rappelle que nous sommes dans
l'otan avec la turquie c'est à dire un
pays qu'il y a quelques semaines a visé
dans un acte d'une très grave hostilités
un de nos bâtiments maritimes
monsieur erdogan est affaibli
politiquement il a des résultats
électoraux qui sont moins bons il a eu
des échecs électoraux
il ya une crise économique patente et
donc il finalement ils utilisent l'islam
à des fins identitaire et politique dans
son pays voilà ce qui se passe mais je
vous met aussi en garde monsieur macron
de ne pas sûr joué finalement
l'indignation à l'origine de ce
mouvement de protestation
les paroles ferme du président français
mercredi lors de l'hommage à samuel
paquin nous ne renoncerons pas aux
caricatures au dessin même si d'autres
reculs on a des doutes sur l'efficacité
du couvre-feu et sur le fait de savoir
si c'est si c'est une demi mesures ou
pas et si à la fin des fins avait
apporté les résultats escomptés je vais
être très clair avec vous je préfère
déconfinement locaux à la toussaint
plutôt qu'un confinement généralisée à
noël
nous avions envisagé évidemment leur
confinement avec la gradation de mesures
allant jusqu'aux confinement notamment
leur confinement locales et donc tout ça
est envisagée sur le plan technique et
opérationnelle moi je pense que oui
évidemment mais comme tout le monde l'a
dit qu'un rebond finement générale
serait évidemment très coûteux mais est
ce que c'est un scénario pour la banque
hre est invitée aujourd'hui soit les
courbes se commence à s'infléchir et on
laisse le couvre-feu dans tel quel on
n'a pas besoin de durcir les mesures
soit on voit que ça ne suffit pas pour
plein de raisons notamment parce que
compte tenu de la météo les gens restent
à l'intérieur et se contaminent beaucoup
plus c'est vraiment la différence par
rapport à l'état et à l'été pardon et
dans ce cas là oui il faudra prendre on
prendre des mesures plus dures la
perspective pour beaucoup de retourner
dans un confinement s'est retournée
maintenant dans quelque chose de connu
à voir ses enfants h 24 à la maison je
pense pas qu'ils étaient parents qui en
vit de nouveau d'avoir à gérer
l'éducation ne jamais les voir c'est pas
mieux quand c'est trop tard c'est trop
tard
voyez personne ne peut faire de miracle
quand on a pris des décisions trop
tardive
quand on n'a pas anticipé quand on n'a
pas prévu et bien à un moment donné il
est trop tard pour les prendre
malheureusement je tombais sur le
bouchon est ainsi nommé cheval a dit
j'ai fait 20 minutes 25 me comme lui de
nombreux automobilistes sont restés
coincés dans les embouteillages à une
amende de 135 euros et pour certains le
dispositif n'est pas très juste formule
planète
une rémission le périple ce sont des
scènes de violence très rare à rome
quelques centaines de manifestants
majoritairement d'extrême droite ont
saccagé cette nuit du mobilier urbain et
renversé des scooters dégradé des
boutiques les blocs les gens à moins de
dix ans que périphérique je me suis dit
une heure pour rentrer ce n'est pas
dépasser la limite quand même ça se
trouve c'est du racket simplement à
naples ce fut plus compliqué des
affrontements opposent et militants
syndicaux et forces de l'ordre devant
les locaux des autorités régionales
les manifestants s'opposent aux mesures
de couvre-feu pour eux s'attaquer à la
liberté de mouvement est une mauvaise
réponse